[Music]
lot thank you so much for being here
with me today of course so I want to
start with you at the very beginning
tell me how you got your start in music
okay this is kind of funny so follow me
my dad is like Street D into cars just
knows a lot of people so I'm around this
like Fast lifestyle and then in school
language arts was always my favorite
subject M tail I
really smart girl I just loved word play
like metaphors simes writing essays and
poems like that was just so second
nature for me so I had this passion and
then this lifestyle I'm already growing
up around it they kind of just like
combin my two worlds so then how did you
start breaking onto the scene walk me
through the stsy tuck so in my
household if you say you want to do
something we doing it full-fledged like
it's not a hobby we we prepping for real
life like we taking it serious like a
career so when I told my dad that I
wanted to rap from that point on I'm
doing talent shows open mics ciphers
hosting like my my flyers around the
city on stop signs we printed up my
mixtapes and we're passing them out at
festivals in Atlanta selling them in
like the Walmart parking lot I'm getting
picked up from school doing my home
homework in the studio Lobby and then
going to the booth like full-fledged
this is your career
now what would you say are some of the
difficulties of managing you know
yourself as a brand everything is
difficult waking up early difficult
scheduling things making sure you know
you're allotting self-care self-time cuz
you can easily crash out with this
industry and just the amount of time it
takes like a lot of people have work a
99 to5 this is like a 12 to 12 so I
think everything about it is difficult
and I really love what I do this is so
strenuous that I would have been quit if
I did not genely enjoy it it's it's so
strenuous and so demanding of your time
and energy it's like I can't even choose
the hardest thing I'm
sure how do you manage that like you
know just flipping into that Business
site the brain cuz you know you're a
creative yeah I really wear so many hats
that it's it's just another one of the
hats it's like at this point it's just
another one of the hats I try to stick
to my expertise which is creative but
I'm going to always have my my nose in
in the business cuz at the end of the
day that that is the goal you know music
don't last forever not going to be this
young and fine forever you
know going along with that you know how
do you handle the stress of con
constantly you know marketing yourself
you're you're kind of your own product
my mind is constantly running like I
have a Notes app in my phone and it
it'll say like PR ideas next video ideas
next photo shoot concept ideas I watch
documentaries I scroll on Pinter even
small things like watching a movie can
like spark interest or spark inspiration
it definitely doesn't
stop who is your dream collaborator both
in the business world and in the music
world business Riri Riri Riri I I just
feel like she touched Our Generation in
in a whole different way like I feel
like women like me who might have like a
little motion little motion going on you
know she showed us that it's possible
for us to take it to a whole different
level so definitely Riri really music
and business what's up Riri call me
girl speaking of that what's next for
you like what are you most excited for
in 2024 I'm excited to see how me
managing myself and I also have a team
too but like for the most part I'm
managing myself where that takes me like
me having two hands on the steering
wheel because I started so young it's
like I'm not used to having to say so
and just being such
a decision maker in my in my career it's
it's been fun to like see my Visions
come to life as a kid you know I feel
like there's always been a lot of cooks
in the kitchen I'm the cook in the
kitchen so 2024 should be very inspiring
and motivating for me for
[Music]
Alysa